cooking is like it doesn't always have
to be stressful I think what's
interesting about right now in the UK
and America is a lot of people are
cooking that never cooked before no I
think what would be nice tonight if we
can cooking can be therapy it can be
real fun yeah I think this dish is a
good one I think you're gonna like it
the great thing about this we're gonna
do a stir fried rice dish and the great
thing about this is it's very flexible
to what your audience will or will not
have okay so it's a rice dish but you
can do it with noodles or you can do it
with both we're gonna use pretty much
any vegetable you can get your hands on
that you can slice up fine so please
please don't stress I mean I've I've got
frozen peas that I'm going to use I can
see there you've got fresh corn so
listen I have got a slightly different
technique this is my expression of a
stir fried rice so I'll talk through the
ingredients just so you audience get
their head around it I've got some
chopped up bacon here the sausage I've
got some leek but you could use spring
onion or red onion white onion I've got
some broccoli you could use any of that
kind of cabbage family I've got some
little corn you've got sweet corn I've
got some ginger some garlic and chili
yeah I'm using some curry paste but you
could use curry powder so there's a
little bit of sort of spice in this dish
I don't think they have that but that's
okay if you haven't got that have you
got any kind of like like jerk spice or
have you got any like Asian spice I
think anything that has a little bit of
a spice blend and a bit of attitude we
can use then i buy some shrimp would you
do you want to try do you want to try a
different technique with the egg yeah
what have you gone egg if not it doesn't
matter yeah I can or I can just show you
mine take the egg we're going to crack
it into a little Bowl
okay crack it into a little
there you go yeah
and then once you've got a little Bowl
you have to give it a little wisp Oh
prepared it so once you once you've done
the whisk we want that can of yours to
be fairly pop and instead of stir-frying
the right into it what I'm going to do
is show you a different technique which
I love it's fun of course you don't have
to do it but I think you're going to
like it so in the pan we're going to put
a little bit of olive oil or oil you can
put it in and then you can you hardly
need any at all and then we're going to
go in the pan and then immediately we're
gonna move move the egg around like a
pancake so as soon as that egg goes in
move it around yeah but it's gonna it's
been almost cook like a crack see that
so as soon as you put it in move the pan
around okay quick quick quick go on go
[Applause]
and then do like one layer like a CREP
or a pancake or whatever you want to
call it yeah okay then put it back on
the heat yeah we're just gonna cook it
for like one minute until it kind of the
side until it kind of moves so look at
mine if you just look at mine right now
I turn this over and I turn it upside
down and out it comes see that yeah let
me show you it's like a sheet yeah so if
it cooked yeah is it cooked all the way
through show me on your camera yeah
pretty pretty nice it's pretty good
that's not what yeah yeah it's brilliant
so now just turn that upside down on
your surface on your on your kitchen
surface okay give it a little tap on
that wooden surface perfect go upside
down give it a tap you may pick it up no
yep no no no don't pick it up
your pan up and turn it upside down like
this okay boom on them on the wooden
surface going sister yeah yeah yeah so
now what we want to do is once you've
kind of rolled it up it doesn't matter
if it's perfect or not perfect I want
you to roll it up like this right see
that roll it up okay I can't see let me
do it again okay so you've got your
piece of pan in your egg yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean once you've done
that you can get your knife and cut it
into 1 centimeter slices almost like
Tiger telly and that's going to be your
egg ribbons that will go through your
rice and it's just a cool quick easy
yeah that's what you get yeah so you
actually get ribbons of egg yeah it's
good
China yeah no no you've done it you've
done it you're amazing yes I'm amazing
thank you go use your hands mix it up
mix it up mix it up I was taught tossed
it around okay okay so that little
technique is just an optional extra you
don't have to do it but I like it and
I'm very proud so we are going to move
on now we're going to put the bacon and
sausage into the pan bacon and sausage
into the yeah very philosophical and
like I said any leftover meat is cool no
don't do that you don't want to overcook
it so when you kind of get into that pan
you can start to see the fat sizzling
we'll hit yeah and I'm just going to
pass back to my daughter so I can do
some jobs
alright the um so I'm gonna just you've
got all your veggies so I start having
you open yes I have you want it to go
like golden so just lightly you know so
on a medium high heat I'd say but if
it's too hot then you know you can turn
it down it's good going well have you
got your ginger chopped up no I'm using
I'm using garlic and ginger to give you
a fragrant here and I've got some basic
veg come have a look at this oops I've
got some baby corn you've got a big corn
I'm just going to cut mine so that's
fine you've taken the corn off the cob
so that's cool
yeah it'll be delicious so if we go over
to the pan here so your fan should be
like mine it should be like get your
golden sitting there my parents my
parents like Europeans okay so now put
your prawns in and your curry paste or
your jerk spice or any spice that you've
got hands on like because we're in
lockdown
not everyone has got the same thing I've
got some curry paste you could use curry
powder jerk spice you can use like Cajun
seasoning any of those little paste or
kind of spice mixes would be cool look
at that yeah you can put that in right
now just about the are keeping you up
quicker than I am the plate goes in the
prawns go in the chilli garlic ginger
okay your mama go now if you go into
your spring onions or onions if you go
in with the corn and your peppers well
just like Eugene you want to do this
thing here hello there what's what's
nice about this dish is you can prep it
up and it's nice to cook it in batches
of like two portions at a time
if you've trying to put too much in
you're not really stir-frying
yeah go for it it's flexible it's a
flexible dish
so once the ventures have like a little
minute then we're going to go in with
our yeah you could once you got the
veggies in then you're giving it a stir
then we'll give it a beat and then we'll
go in with a rice and obviously what
we're trying to do at home is not the
easiest thing we're trying to mimic wok
frying which is very high temperature in
a big whoop so obviously at home it's
the biggest pan you've got and now we're
gonna go in with the rice okay well you
got to remember I mean you can cook it a
bit more but we don't want to overcook
the veg we want to kind of like capture
the texture we want to kind of retain as
much nutrients as possible and by the
way you know one of the best things you
can do at the moment you know to keep
your immune system hi hi
is dead many fruits embeds and nice
things in there in with a rice in with
the rice you can use two spoons if you
want to go I just use the back of the
spoon that's it you're doing a great job
honestly really good job what we're
gonna do now have you got any chili
sauce I think that's cool so if you have
a shitty sauce you can use a black bean
sauce or you can use a hoisin sauce
resources they're everywhere I haven't
got any chili sauce so I'm just adding a
little tiny bit of hoisin yeah that's
good season it with soy sauce just about
a tablespoon we get the low salt stuff
yeah really good I would suggest that
you do it creatively from a height and
eye height yeah yeah just for fun no
reason so now we're gonna go in with
these lovely eggs to be honest you're
done so you can remove it turn the heat
off now that's cool yep pop them on top
they don't need much for anything now
one thing I like to do is just taste the
seasoning you might want to add a little
bit more soy sauce you want to get that
seasoning right so it's got flavor
yeah we're shippi it's got the it's got
the magico touch now what's what you can
do I like see if you got it really
really really have you got any citrus in
there that's really well done really
well seasoned now do i mix some ribbons
or leave them on top have you got any
citrus yeah we got lots of citrus around
here because a good squeeze of that is
so good with the seafood because in
California California yes it'll be so
good I'm just gonna hand back to my
lovely daughter right gone gone so we're
gonna do now yes spoon toss - I'm just
going to spoon it onto a plate now it's
always higher pressure when you're kind
of doing lives and not like it's not
when you're at home on your own you can
just chill out and you have a glass of
wine flip it back for me pops yeah are
you done it yes that's it yeah you did
it you smashed it come on girl you did
so well if you want more advice wisdom
guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me
I hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there let me
set that part aside let me give you a
complete different side that we have to
look at look